espejito espejito aquí nos muestras hoy
a nadie porque están cubiertos de cera
en la galería de los espejos del palacio
de versalles y ahora está grabando el
vídeo de su colección prêt-à-porter
otoño-invierno 2021-2022 porque debido a
la pandemia aún no hay desfiles así que
las marcas creando espectáculos cuentan
historias
maria grazia chiuri eligió llevarnos al
mundo de los cuentos de hadas
no es tiempo que no eran simplemente los
cuentos de hadas sino contar los sueños
detrás de estos para detectarla en
tópicos me fascinó descubrir que todos
los cuentos de hadas modernos que
conocemos hoy fueron escritos en francia
en el siglo 17 en versalles por mujeres
de sangre eso no es muy conocido women
existen cuentos escritos por mujeres muy
revolucionario en esa época the original
center for the times the sun tenga
devolución a la caperucita roja alicia
en el país de las maravillas' princesas
punk con smoky eyes múltiples personajes
con personalidades únicas y yo hablar
realmente de las mujeres de cómo con la
ropa que usan pueden volverse un
personaje diferente
news porque los cuentos de hadas hablan
de la metamorfosis y otro aspecto muy
importante para mí también es el vínculo
que hice cuando empecé este proyecto que
es un proyecto coral con esta artista
italiana silva jean bronze
porque en los cuentos de hadas hay
algunos aspectos y algunos objetos muy
presentes como el espejo
y el espejo es un elemento que está
presente en nuestra vida está presente
en la moda
pero probablemente nunca pensamos en lo
mucho que éste influye en nosotros
mismos awards art
de hecho ella cubrió los espejos con
cera porque no quiere que reflejen ni
una imagen de actor frank en cierto modo
quiero decirnos que si queremos
construir nuestra identidad
probablemente no deberíamos mirarnos al
espejo
la artista italiana silvia giambroni
lucha contra todas las formas de
dominación sus obras son una invitación
a que no nos preocupemos por la opinión
de los demás
ah
estamos en la galería de los espejos
grades de kent wells estos espejos
debían mostrar lo poderoso y grande que
era el rey cambiar al simbólico
mi idea era venir y sustituir
simbólicamente estos espejos por los
míos
hay que considerar feminist merz bikers
porque ponen en conflicto este lugar
donde antes había poder
where they estuve esta galería de los
espejos representa históricamente el
poder del patriarcado el clic de power
patrick y no negamos la historia pero
podemos transformar la simbólicamente
transforma
por lo que hago es quitar los cristales
y ponerles cera y espinas para mostrar
el tipo de conflicto que a veces nos
refleja la imagen de nosotros mismos
completa desde metrovías el sun-times
reflex twitter
la moda viste los cuerpos la danza les
da vida maria grazia chiuri recurrió a
la coreografía israel hincharon ella
sí
bien
piernas fuertes si más rápido todavía y
extremo muchas veces siento que los
bailarines son esculturas que cobran
vida el nombre de esta colección es the
stars being boring belleza perturbadora
es algo con lo que realmente conecto ya
que para mí la belleza proviene de un
sentimiento perturbador
con respeto a la casa que la eligió
maria grazia chiuri fue a curiosear en
los archivos porque la idea no perder un
legado fantástico
[Música]
the collection y la colección es una
verdadera colección prêt à porter
no quiero realizar una colección que sea
un disfraz porque estamos hablando de
prêt à porter
así que es una colección que creo que
representa de alguna manera mi visión de
una nueva generación de mujeres york
nate code mantengo el código de la casa
y lo traduzco de forma contemporánea con
diferentes atuendos con diferentes
materiales más contemporáneos y traigo
algunas impresiones de los archivos
porque encontré esta increíble historia
porque cada vez encuentro algo nuevo en
los archivos y todos los patrones de
misterios
en cuanto a cómo se ve maria grazia
chiuri a sí misma
[Música]
en país no tengo espejo y discutimos de
eso con mi hija porque cuando llegó a
parís dijo no no es posible una casa sin
espejo
le dije no te preocupes hay uno en el
ascensor puedes ir a mirar en el
ascensor
de leaf yo no suelo mirarme en el espejo
sinceramente es algo que no me interesa
mucho
y eso probablemente sea muy bueno para
mí
recién ahora lo entendí
nunca pienso mucho en eso pero realmente
creo que fue algo muy bueno para mí
for my self
increíble no viniendo de una mente tan
inventiva después de todo porque no
intentarlo para acabar descubriendo nos
a nosotros mismos tal y como somos
[Música]